[Music]
where as long as I knew Eugene he had
his sights set on space all these years
later I can't believe he's still up
there my man on the moon
[Music]
Eugene and I were married 46 years I
first met Eugene when he was studying
geology at Princeton he would tell me
about all the secrets the earth held and
of course his favorite those impact
craters soon enough he got me to fall in
love with those rocks too after the kids
had grown and were out of the house I
was looking for something to do and gene
suggested maybe I would like to see
things through the telescope we spent
our days holed up in Lowell Observatory
[Music]
when Kennedy announced that they were
going to send a man to the moon gene was
terribly excited gene wanted to go to
the moon more than anything else then he
got the medical test Addison's disease
his immune system wasn't protecting him
the way it needed to you they couldn't
risk him leaving Earth he felt like his
goal had suddenly disappeared at the
same time he was not a quitter
he set up his own mock lunar site and
trained Neil Armstrong and the rest of
the boys before they took off our focus
changed over the years from looking up
at the moon and looking at the sky to
how the earth was formed we packed up
and crisscross Australia looking for
signs of impact craters
on the day of the accident you're just
looking off in the distance talking
about how much fun we were having and
then suddenly there appeared the land
rover in front of us there was no time
to think the two vehicles collided and
Jean died article while I was in the
hospital he said they're about to send a
mission up to the moon I wonder if you
would like to put jeans ashes on the
moon and so I said I think that would be
wonderful
the whole family was there to wave Jean
goodbye after the mission was completed
it ran out of fuel and it crashed into
the moon and that's where jeans ashes
are now suddenly the man who spent his
whole life studying craters had made his
own impact
I miss him always but to this day I can
look up at the moon and imagine him
there with his rocks looking down at me
he still lights up every single one of
my night skies
you
[Music]